there's viral posts that 2 plus 2 is
equal to 5 and it goes like this
negative 20 is equal to negative 20 that
means 16 minus 36 is equal to 25 minus
45 add 81 over 4 to both sides write the
equation in terms of factors then Factor
the left hand side as the square of 4
minus 9 over 2 and the right hand side
is the square of 5 minus sine over two
this means 4 minus 9 over 2 is equal to
5 minus 9 over 2 which means 4 is equal
to 5 or 2 plus 2 is equal to 5. so
where's the mistake the mistake is in
this step you cannot remove the Square
from both sides of the equation clearly
the square of negative 1 is equal to the
square of one but the next step says
negative 1 is equal to 1 and that is
false this implication is not true the
reason is that if x is equal to Y then x
squared is equal to Y squared but if x
squared is equal to Y squared we only
know that x squared minus y squared is
equal to 0 which means we can factor and
get that X is equal to y or X is equal
to negative Y and that is why 2 plus 2
is not equal to 5.